hey America We Need to Talk were the
least American America since my daddy
snuck into America from Cuba I'm Ted
Cruz and I plan to take America back to
when we were American I should know i
was born in canada this is my five-point
plan for a more American America point
one my hate for Obamacare made me famous
among conservatives now I'm so famous
I'm running for president so that's why
I'm signing my whole family up to
Obamacare because it's free where I work
and I've got to pay for a presidential
campaign to roll back Obamacare point2
I'm a disrupter just let the most
successful tech startups I'm disrupting
everything I'm like the uber
ex-president I've never been a president
before but heck I think I could drive
this country full time I love technology
disruption so much that's why I stole my
logo from tinder and you better believe
it I only swipe right point 3 we need to
forget about the environment it'll
always be there but we will if God
didn't want us to burn fossil fuels he
wouldn't have put fossils in the ground
in the first place point for if there's
one thing I hate more than big
government it is big religion there are
over 300 religious traditions in this
country they all can't be right some are
a little to the left we need to roll
back those faiths to the ones we know
work point five being a one term senator
I don't have a lack of experience I just
have a brain in brand new condition it's
ready to be used fresh out of the pack
the problem with the other presidential
nominees is that their brains have been
used over and over again they've thought
about things too hard and that can ruin
your brain it makes sense think about it
I'm Ted Cruz and I always look like I'm
about to cry